[MUSIC]
I spent years trying to see
All That Jazz on the big screen.
I see a lot of movies, and
it's one of my absolute favorites.
It's kind of a musical,
and it's definitely sexy.
It reckons with Bob Fosse,
the Cabaret in Chicago Guy, as he chases
his own ambitions rather than cultivating
relationships with the people he loves.
Because of that,
it's a movie that all of us should see.
I had the chance to see All That Jazz on
a pristine 35 millimeter film print this
summer in Los Angeles.
The energy of the crowd was infectious,
as we all took in this
beautiful film together.
Even my girlfriend, who hates musicals
because they're not cynical enough,
walked away, impressed by the film.
I made her have the chance to see
All That Jazz in a theatre again.
It's a Fox movie.
And after Disney acquired Fox,
they've slowly started pulling all Fox
films from theatrical distribution.
Copyright lasts 95 years, so
this movie might not be in
a theater again until 2075.
Now, you might not care about All That
Jazz, but what about Alien, or Titanic?
These are classic Fox films,
and they might not be in theatres
again until after most of us are gone.
Ideas are too important for
someone to own forever.
The public domain allows all of us to
own creative ideas like stories and
characters.
The problem is copyright
keeps getting longer,
and this is preventing new work
from entering the public domain.
Imagine a world where the idea for
the light bulb and its production has been
owned by one person since it was invented.
The world would literally
be a darker place.
The light bulbs would
be insanely expensive,
and there probably wouldn't be much
innovation on the light bulb front.
Now think about a world where you
had to pay Shakespeare's estate
every time you adapted one of his plays.
Amazing movies like Ten Things I
Hate About You, Westside Story, or
The Lion King, might not exist if
studios had to pay for these rights.
Thankfully, these plays
are in the public domain.
So creators are able to pull from them to
create any crazy thing they can imagine.
This has the added benefit of keeping
his stories and characters alive.
Plays and stories written in the 20th
century are not as lucky as Shakespeare's.
This is because copyright
keeps getting longer.
At the start of the 20th century,
copyright lasted 42 years.
This eventually bumped up to 56 years,
75 years, and
95 years, their lobbying efforts.
The result of this is that no new work
enter the public domain from 1998 to 2019.
That's 20 years of stories sitting
on shelves when they could be
thriving before our eyes.
We've decided that some ideas are not too
important for someone to own forever.
Copyright last 95 years,
but patents only last 20.
That's tacit acknowledgment that as
a society we think that transistors and
telephones matter less than our books and
our movies.
I strongly disagree with this.
Technology can lengthen or
improve our lives, but
to quote author Joan Didion, we tell
ourselves stories in order to live.
Only through stories can you step outside
your life and into somebody else's life.
The public domain actually
makes work more valuable.
Let's take a look at the Wizard of Oz.
The original novel was published
by L Frank Baum, in 1900.
MGM purchased the rights, and
in 1939 they released that
famous Judy Garland adaptation.
The thing is,
copyright was shorter in the 20th century.
So by the 1970s, most of the novels and
the sequels of the novels
entered the public domain.
This opened up the floodgates for
new adaptations of the Wizard of Oz.
Adaptations like sci-fi channel's Tin Man,
or
Disney's really bizarre movie,
Return to Oz.
>> [LAUGH]
>> These are kind of creepy examples,
so they're probably
working against my point.
But what about something unimpeachable
like The Wiz, or Wicked?
I love these musicals, and you might too.
And they might not exist
without the public domain.
The public domain has created
far more economic value out
of the Wizard of Oz than just royalty
payments to L Frank Baum and his heirs.
It's also kept his stories alive.
Mickey Mouse represents a world of
more restrictive copyright terms.
Mickey is ubiquitous.
You can find them on iPhone cases,
or dish towels.
You might even have photos of
him from your family vacation.
But that's the problem,
Mickey's no longer a character.
He's a piece of corporate iconography.
What was the last great
Mickey Mouse cartoon?
I would argue, Fantasia?
And that came out in 1940.
Disney is not telling great
Mickey Mouse stories.
And Mickey's soul has been trapped
in the Disney vault since 1928.
There's good news though.
Mickey's going to be free in just four
years, his copyright expires in 2024.
Let me tell you what's going to happen.
I promise you,
Disney is going to be just fine.
First of all, the copyright only covers
the original Mickey Mouse cartoons like
Steamboat Willie Any
updates to his character or
his design are covered
under future copyrights.
So they're still covered.
Any of the imagery that is
used in corporate logos
actually counts as trademark and
that lasts forever.
Disney's done an amazing job building
an intellectual property moat
with characters like Goofy,
or Donald Duck.
These characters came out later, so
the copyrights are going to expire later.
All Mickey expiring is going to do is
incentivize Disney to tell the best
Mickey Mouse stories they can,
on a more open market.
Now, I'm not advocating for
an abolition of copyright.
I want to make movies one day, and
I think creators deserve to be paid for
their work.
Copyright protects that right.
I also recognize that it's
probably impractical to shorten
copyright terms from where they stand now.
I just want to make sure
they don't get any longer.
Characters like Mickey deserve to be free.
Remember, ideas are too important for
someone to own forever.
Remember this, if you ever have the chance
to work with content in your career,
your instinct may be to hoard this content
by advocating for longer copy right terms.
Please don't do this.
>> [LAUGH].
>> After 95 years, stories and characters
are better off in the hands of everyone.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]